Twenty one all one word better.
Twenty one saves you just a massive amount
on a membership of your choice at Join Pakman
Dotcom.
So there's now a discussion happening about
how soon Joe Biden and Democrats should wait
for Republicans to negotiate on the covid
relief bill before just going forward and
passing it without Republican support via
budget reconciliation if Democrats have the
votes in the Senate.
Now, there are people criticizing Joe Biden.
Why is Joe Biden meeting with Republicans
about the covid bill?
Why is Joe Biden inviting 10 Democrats, 10
Republican senators to meet as he did last
night?
When these people are clearly bad faith actors,
there's not going to be unity.
There's not going to be negotiation.
That gets us anything close to what Joe Biden
wants, which is a one point nine trillion
dollar package.
And I basically agree with all of that other
than to say the meeting is fine.
Let's just understand that after the meeting,
Republicans, as we've already seen them do
this morning, are going to insist that they
want some pathetic 600 billion dollar stimulus
bill, these same senators who now are going
back to the tired old tropes of Republicans,
we can't afford it, but where's the money
going to come from?
But inflation.
But the debt, but the deficit.
People who said nothing as Trump exploded
the deficit despite claiming he would pay
off the entire national debt during his first
term, these same Republican senators gleefully,
happily voted for 740 billion dollars for
the military budget just recently.
So they are hypocrites.
They are exactly who we believed them to be.
They are going to obstruct and get in the
way and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Joe Biden's proposal is for one point nine
trillion dollars.
These Republicans want 618 billion.
And they met yesterday with Joe Biden.
So I think that the meeting with them is fine
as long as Joe Biden and Democrats are ready
to say, listen.
Remember, they promised 2000 dollar checks
would go out right away.
It's February now, right away we could debate
what right away means and government speak.
But Joe Biden definitely made us think, John
USCIRF definitely made us think that the checks
were going out quickly.
It's been a couple of weeks almost now.
OK, so it's time to do it, have the meeting
with the Republicans, but understand that
Republicans are going to make all sorts of
demands.
They are going to demand capitulation to their
ideology, to their platform.
They will weaken the bill.
They will weaken the impact of the bill.
And ultimately, even if you come up with something
that's between 600 billion and one point nine
trillion, they'll probably still refuse to
vote for it anyway.
OK, these are not good faith actors.
So don't be mad that Joe Biden is meeting
with Republicans.
I'm fine with it.
It's fine that he's doing it.
He claimed he wants bipartisanship and unity
and all this stuff.
That's fine.
They were able to propose their six hundred
billion dollar package and they are likely
to vote against whatever compromise Democrats
end up proposing.
So my view is give them a meeting and then
pass one point nine trillion without a single
Republican, if that's what they want to do.
Now, you need Jim, if you don't get a single
Republican, you need Joe Manchin to vote.
And we need to be sure that Joe Manchin is
going to vote for it.
Republicans will shriek.
They will demand that they be met halfway.
They will say, what about unity?
What about bipartisanship, blah, blah, blah.
But when it's Democrats asking Republicans
to meet them halfway, when Trump is in power,
remember what Republicans said?
Well, elections have consequences.
We're not going to just because you guys want
this different thing.
Trump won and we control this and we control
that.
So Democrats should have a spine and be ready
because for an issue to have a compromise,
both sides have to concede things to make
that work.
The Republican Party is not offering to concede
anything.
The Democratic proposal is one point nine
trillion and it's popular with the American
people.
Republicans are just saying no.
Is the concession that they will grant any
money because remember, many Republican voters
want the stimulus package as well.
This is not a stimulus package that is only
popular with Democratic voters.
Republicans are not conceding anything.
They are negotiating when they don't actually
have leverage if Joe Biden and Democrats are
actually ready and willing to pass this without
a single Republican vote.
So my suggestion is ignore the bad faith whining
of Republicans.
Democrats are passing popular bills that 60,
70, 80 percent of Americans support.
The executive order on asking from Joe Biden.
And you can't you know, we talk about we don't
want to stoop to their level.
We don't want to do what they do.
Listen, we're not obstructing anything.
Joe Biden one Democrats control the House.
Democrats took the Senate voters, including
independents, Democrats, but also Republicans
want the stimulus.
So just pass it.
You gave them their meeting.
It's time to pass it.
You promised you would do it.
And I hope that they actually do.
This could be the first major success of the
Biden administration.
And it will show that it's Joe Biden who will
set the agenda and Democrats, not Mitch McConnell,
or this will be the first major failure for
Joe Biden.
And it will be a big failure.
When you say if I win and OSF and Warnaco
in 2000, checks are going out right away and
we get into February 10th, mid-February, late
February, and you still don't have anything
passed or you end up passing something that's
pathetic and paltry.
That's not going to look good.
So it's time to get it together.
Let's, as we like to say, put on our big boy
pants and get this thing done.
These people, these Republicans are not your
friends.
They're not going to help you.
They're not looking to compromise.
They're looking to get in your way.
You've got to go round them on this important
issue.
Hey, this is super interesting.
CNN did an analysis of the Trump rioters who
have been arrested and found that many of
these Trump rioters who were rioting because
they believe the will of the people was not
done and that somehow Joe Biden is going to
be president, even though Donald Trump really
won the election.
A lot of those Trump rioters didn't even vote.
This may not be a surprise to many of you.
CNN obtained voting records for more than
80 of the initial arrestees.
The majority did vote in the presidential
election, but a bunch of them are not even
registered to vote.
There are a whole bunch of people who either
aren't registered or did not vote in the 2020
election.
And this is interesting for for a number of
different reasons.
First of all, had they voted, they may not
have felt the need to storm the Capitol because
Donald Trump might actually have won it if
a lot of these rightist insurrectionists had
voted.
Now, I know it's only a few thousand people
who went to D.C.
I'm including in that people just generally
supportive of the riotous insurrection.
What is very clear and and unfortunate, unfortunate
in terms of what it means about American culture
and society, is that conspiracy theories are
far more compelling than simply going out
and voting and participating in the democratic
system that we claim to have.
They didn't vote, but they're sure that Donald
Trump must have won because hold on a second,
even they couldn't be bothered to vote.
And that is really something that should cause
some self reflection.
If you are saying, I am sure Trump won because
clearly more people must have voted for him.
But wait a second.
I didn't even vote if I didn't vote.
There's probably lots of people who prefer
Trump who didn't vote.
That moment of self reflection seems to never
come.
And before you know it, there in Washington,
D.C., breaking windows and getting into the
Capitol and messing with Nancy Pelosi's desk
or whatever they were doing.
Imagine that the concept of stop the steal
of our votes when we didn't even vote, stop
stealing our votes.
I mean, other like I didn't vote.
Okay, yeah, but I'm talking about other people.
It's an incredible situation.
And many may even have stayed home because
Donald Trump said it was rigged, which again
raises the idea of whether Trump himself,
by saying it's rigged, don't vote early, don't
vote by mail or do vote by mail, depending
on the state, but not unsolicited ballots.
All of that stuff may also have held down
turnout in a way that was damaging to Donald
Trump.
Now, I have to be very real with you guys
with how close it was.
It's probably a good thing that a lot of these
people didn't vote.
Trump really might have won.
If a lot of these people voted, it may have
been Trump himself who suppress turnout just
enough to prevent him from even winning.
And that's a really scary thought when you
think about how close it was and how it came
down to.
I know that we talk about a massive popular
vote victory and the same electoral margin
for Joe Biden then Trump won with in 2016.
But it came down to, you know, hundred and
sixty to one 100000 votes in a few states,
much like the 2016 election.
Now, big picture, it is not uncommon that
people who complain about government doing
or not doing something don't even vote.
That's not new.
That's not surprising.
In the United States, often half the country
doesn't vote.
Much more than half the country complains,
but often half the country doesn't vote.
In this particular election, it was about
35, 40 percent of the country that didn't
vote.
It's an ideology of meems conspiracy theories
and sharing fake news on Facebook that often
doesn't actually include voting.
They are more loyal to violence and lies than
they are to the just basic democratic systems
that we have in the United States.
And that's a really difficult thing to change
when we talk about deprogramming.
I'm going to have more to say about this maybe
tomorrow or Thursday.
When we talk about deprogramming, we have
to understand that this culture runs really
deep.
Someone who is committed to sharing fake news
but can't be bothered to vote.
It goes beyond just convincing them that their
ideas are wrong.
It goes very, very much beyond that.
Let's take a quick break.
Make sure you're following The David Pakman
Show on Instagram at David Pakman, The David
Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.